on microsoft
because they recently purchased bethesda
so elder scrolls is in their hands
i'm watching you microsoft did not screw
up my favorite game so um yeah
i'm not speaking for microsoft i haven't
i have an explicit arrangement with them
where i don't speak for them obviously
like that should be very clear i do not
speak for them
um i i am not saying um i like him i
think such is amazing um
the term data dignity was coined by
sacha
like so you you know we have
uh it's it's kind of extraordinary but
you know microsoft's this giant thing
it's gonna screw up this or that you
know it's not
i don't know it's kind of interesting
i've had a few occasions in my life to
see how things
work from the inside of some big thing
and you know it's always just people
kind of
it it's
i don't know there's always like
coordination problems
and there's also there's always there's
human problems oh there's some good
people there's some bad people as always
i hope microsoft doesn't screw up
and i hope they bring cliffy back you
should never kill clippy bring clippy
back oh clippy but clippy promotes the
myth of a.i
well that's why
you're wrong how about if we all right
could we bring back bob instead of
clippy which one was bob oh bob was
another thing like bob was this other
screen character who is supposed to be
the voice of ai cortana cortana with
cortana dude for you cortana is too
corporate
i like it
there's a there's a woman in seattle
who's like the model for cortana did
cortana's voice and was there there was
like no the voice is great we had a vis
we had her as a she used to walk around
and if you were wearing hololens for a
bit i don't think that's happening
anymore i think i don't think you should
turn a software software into a creature
well you and i yeah
hedgehog
you